là c'est une c'est quand même une pointe
de une pointe de colère et d'énervement
qui commença qui commence à monter parce
qu'il ya d'une part le sentiment que il
ya de vrais incohérences dans le
dispositif et puis le sentiment surtout
que c'est un choix politique c'est à
dire que ce n'est pas un choix qui est
uniquement choix sanitaire c'est un
choix qui est politique
finalement on n'est pas un secteur non
essentiel pour le gouvernement on est un
secteur inutiles ou bien le secteur que
l'on peut toucher finalement sans que ça
fasse beaucoup de mal
pour l'instant on a été extrêmement
j'allais dire presque dos il est
certainement un peu trop docile donc il
ya de fortes chances que l'on utilise
les voies de droit qui sont à notre
disposition et le mans delà de la
culture et des arts est aussi structuré
en association en syndicat donc il ya de
fortes chances que ce soit la décision
qui va être prise
les conséquences sont multiples cédé 6
et les conséquences financières
finalement pour le théâtre vont j'allais
dire presque au second plan même si
elles sont considérables mais c'est des
conséquences pour les publics et puis
des conséquences pour des artistes qui
sont qui sont considérables c'est à dire
que la période qui va de novembre
jusqu'au mois de janvier c'est la
période traditionnellement dé ce qu'on
appelle les sorties de création
c'est-à-dire les premières des
spectacles les premières que les
programmateurs peuvent voir pour les
programmes et la saison suivante
cette période là n'existe pas c'est à
dire que vous avez des dizaines des
centaines de compagnies qui ont
travaillé pendant un an deux ans trois
ans pour monter des productions qui
devait sortir là et qui ne sortiront pas